so I feel like I should tell you guys
before I do this review that I'm a big
fan of the Resident Evil game for the
fourth one being my favorite I love this
game it was amazing to me just telling
you that you could probably get an idea
of how I feel about these films Resident
Evil retribution or Resident Evil 5 to
those who haven't been counting there
are five of these now five of them now
I'm not a fan of these movies at all
alright I went into this movie with
absolutely zero optimism but if this
movie was good I would have eaten my
words and said you know what this
movie's actually good
I like these games but good job Paul WS
Anderson you actually made a good movie
that's not the case at all just let you
know this is a horrible movie but let's
talk about the plot uh yeah there's no
plot Millia yo vich is in some sort of
world where they control her mind or
something she's in some facility of some
kind and then the Red Queen hologram
little girl from the first film is back
she wakes up and it's like she's in a
normal world of a sense like oh okay
here I am and here's my my family and
let's just let just live this life
that's fine oh no that actually there's
zombies outside and so is Michelle
Rodriquez in some random character she's
never been in before then she realizes
she's in some kind of elaborate hologram
or something this is all was in the
first like ten minutes of the movie I'm
not spoiling a thing I mean this
literally wasn't like the first ten
minutes of the movie she wakes up in
this cylindrical tube like room she's
all half-naked like in the fifth element
and everything then she realizes she was
in some kind of hologram world for like
two minutes and that they were projected
images and this daughter that she was
caring about was actually a fake
projected a hologram of some kind and
now she has to try to get out of this
facility because there's all these
creatures in there they're trying to
kill her and now she's suddenly attached
to this holographic daughter this this
daughter that's not real she's not
really her mother you don't really
understand what's going on you really
don't because is this a real little girl
because they started treating her like
she's real because two seconds ago she
was a hologram and not real at all and
all of a sudden you're supposed to care
about her where's this relationship
gonna go this little girl that you're
carrying about to hologram right or did
I miss that I don't know I feel like an
idiot but this script is absolutely
horrible two are the worst scripts of
the year for sure Paul WS Anderson man
okay let's continue with this review
that I got that out of the way but to go
on any more I really feel like I
to examine the Resident Evil franchise
why do these films get made because from
what I can see the majority of people
aren't really fans of them but they
continuously get made let's look at a
few things that I have done some
research about the first Resident Evil
film had a budget of 33 million dollars
and it grossed 102 million dollars
worldwide Resident Evil Apocalypse had a
slightly larger budget of forty five
million dollars and it grossed one
hundred and twenty nine million dollars
worldwide extinction had the exact same
budget of forty five million dollars yet
it grossed one hundred and forty seven
million dollars worldwide now the last
one before this one afterlife had a
budget of sixty million and that grows
two hundred and ninety six million
dollars worldwide 60 million of that was
from the United States people in other
countries love these movies they love
them for some reason the point I'm
trying to make is these films are all
made for a micro budget right about the
same they've all gone up a little bit
except for the two that stayed at forty
five all of them make their budget back
almost to the exact dollar in the United
States and then for some reason in other
countries it's this humongous gross
that's where these movies keep getting
made because people pay to see them
there's no love of film in this director
or these producers this is purely just a
money generating franchise and that's
all it is there's nothing about the
games there's just certain characters
like Leon that appears Jill Valentine
one of the main characters from the
first game is a villain in this movie
for no reason at all there's no reason
for these movies to exist except to
steal your money from you and yet people
continuously pay for them for no reason
therefore Baloo bees stopped paying for
these movies there are so many stupid
things that happen in this movie I'm
going to list a few of the ones that I
can at least think of number one the
plot is incomprehensible you it's dumb
number two it's dumb number three every
action scene is in slow motion
everything is in slow motion there's no
sense of realism or excitement or
suspense of any kind in these action
scenes because everything is in slow
motion the matrix came out in 1999 Paul
WS Anderson stop copying it it did it
you slow motion sparingly it had most of
the action incomplete actual motion the
way you can actually see them fighting
and you can see what they're doing and
then slow motion was added just at a few
right spots to make you go wow that was
amazing
this film copies off the Matrix it
copies off aliens there's a part where
this giant creature kills like everyone
okay there's there's no reason for this
creature to show any mercy of any kind
it kills everyone in sight
it sees the little girl the little
hologram girl we're supposed to care for
it just takes her and puts her in some
thing that preserves her alive just like
in aliens for no reason at all seeing
aliens at work because the alien
creatures cocooned people so they could
continue their race because they let the
people survive just long enough to
impregnate them with their alien babies
that made sense this movie it makes no
sense it's just oh there's a little girl
I'm going to put her in some slime ball
things so the hero can go rescue her
there's no suspense in that scene at all
it's just so fleeting and it just passes
right by it's horrible there's a scene
in the movie where a character gets out
of a sticky situation by like blasting a
hole through ice this one person falls
in the ice and there's zombies under
there somehow swimming in the ice and
okay we're good now right why can't the
zombies just crawl up through the hole
of course they can't do that they're not
going to all crawl up to the hole
because the hero's up there now they're
gonna stay down in the ice that's what
they're gonna do even though there's a
giant opening now for them to crawl up
and kill her it doesn't matter random
things happen okay like in the very
beginning of the movie when she is
imprisoned in this strange cylindrical
cell Wesker just appears out of nowhere
and says you have to do all this and let
me explain everything to you and
actually I'm explaining it to the
audience because the audience is dumb
enough to not be able to figure it out
themselves
that's what Paul Dobie was saying is I
was thinking as he wrote the screenplay
anyway she's in prison okay she's in
this cell alright magically just a
drawers goes and there's all of her
clothes and weaponry and everything just
in her prison cell why is it there no
there's nothing ah michelle rodriquez it
in this movie because apparently she's
michelle rodriquez
and she is a horrible actress my word
everyone in this movie is awful the
character ADA who is you know from
Resident Evil for long
dress in everything every line she says
is audio dubbed I am convinced that's
not her voice 100% not her voice at all
this is one of the worst films I've seen
all year as I've said the only reason
these movies exist are to generate money
for studios there are so many great
directors out there who have a vision
who want to make something that actually
matters
something that will impact cinema
something that will be art and they
don't get to make their movies these
studios just continue to let people like
Paul WS Anderson make his Resident Evil
movies and his three musketeer movie and
everything and just their horrible Paul
WS Anderson writes his movies like a
little four-year-old and I'm sick of it
okay I'm sick of it dude stop making
movies with everything's in slow motion
where the script is horrible you have an
idea of how to frame a shot I can tell
that you have an idea of how to make a
good looking movie you just they're so
bad dude stop everything you do in your
movies looks like green screens it
does like I said I'm a fan of the games
I told you I would review the film
objectively I'm sorry it's not just
because I like the games that I'm hating
on this movie is because it's a terrible
movie please do not see it Resident Evil
retribution for sure gets an F just
don't see it it's it's terrible thanks
for watching guys and as always if you
like this then you can click right here
and get stuck mine eyes